one of the important aspects of the
symbolism of the right and the left
has to do with authority and power that
is the two ways in which influence can
be conducted on others on the world on
society and so what I want to do is I'm
going to continuing my last video on the
symbolism of the left on the right hand
I'm going to continue in this direction
but we're going to look at how the
symbolism of left and right applies to
the very important aspect of authority
and Power in the world
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
it's one of the important aspects of
symbolism as I've often said is that it
is fractal that is the symbolism of the
left and the right as I've talked about
in my last video about the dasis of how
it appears as the figures that are next
to Christ the mother of God sent John
The Foreigner Saint Peter Saint Paul but
that symbolism is already included
inside the icon of the panto krator the
icon the panto crador is the image of
Christ as the returning Christ or the
Christ as the ruler of all as the judge
of all and so you have it a beautiful
example here by the Contemporary
iconographer Aiden Hart
and so in this image the image is
separated left and right and on the
right side of Christ or on his right he
is blessing with his hand
and on his left side he is holding a
book now
already in this structure you will see
that the basic symbolism of the left and
the right is being maintained and even
the crossover between the symbolism that
I mentioned in the last video of how one
seems to move into the other you can see
something like that in this already in
this structure and so Christ is blessing
with his right hand and this symbol that
he does this this manner in which to
hold his hands we we say that it is a
blessing but the origin of this is
actually the hand of a dress that is it
is Christ addressing us and of course
we've come to interpret that as a
blessing in the Catholic church for
example you will see priests that will
bless with do it making this gesture you
also sometimes see Orthodox priests do
that as well
um but it has so the notion of blessing
and of address has come together but
what's important to understand it is
something like direct influence that is
if I speak to you if I believe bless you
if I address you then I am directly as a
person
influencing you right my my uh my
relationship with you is direct but at
the same time it is also flexible
because orality has uh an impermanence
to it in terms of its its manifestation
right so I say something and then it
vanishes right it only it only is
retained in your memory it doesn't have
physical instantiation so because of
that it is also more flexible so it's
direct and it's flexible and on the left
hand he's holding a book now this book
is interpreted in several ways some
people sometimes say it's the book of
The Gospel but it's better to understand
this book as the book of life that's
described in Revelation the book of
books right it's you could say it's just
a book or it it is a book in in you know
it's the the book of books right is the
best way to say that
um but what's important to understand
the difference between of course the the
right hand and the left hand or the
address and the book is is that the
influence of a book is indirect right so
I don't have the person in front of me
talking to me I've got something that
they've said that is written on a piece
of paper and now there's a distance
between that what the person is saying
and the book right so I've talked about
how the right hand is a stand-in for the
center the right hand hand is a moving
towards the center in this case it's a
straight direct influence and the left
hand is moving away from the center and
in this case it is this distance which
appears in writing and but at the same
time it is also fixed and so you could
understand if you look at even at the
last judgment you can understand that
the direct address is a living it's a
living breath it's a living influence
that I'm having on you whereas the left
hand and the book is more dead you could
say right because it it can become dead
letter right it's not just that but it
can become something like dead letter
where it's just a where the text has
lost its Spirit that's a possibility so
you can understand now where why the the
the right hand and the left hand is
represented this way in this image now
what's important to understand in the
basic structure of the pantocrator is
that this is based on a Roman tradition
it's based on ancient Roman art
and so I will show you this is a statue
of the emperor Titus and in the I the
emperor is doing two things with his
right hand he is addressing
and with his left hand he is holding a
scroll and so you can see the same
structure in this image I could have
shown you other images but this is this
was the one that I had where you can see
the Roman Emperor as as using that
Duality right addressing with his right
hand and then holding the scroll in his
left hand and this structure is
understood by most art historians as
also representing Authority and power a
toritas and protestas is the way that
the the lad would have said it and the
structure of authoritas and protestas is
the basic structure to understand the
manner in which Roman society functioned
and so the way that Roman society
function during the Republic you had the
Senators now the Senators they actually
didn't have a they didn't have an
explicit role in the managing of the
nation they didn't have uh Power in the
immediate and executive power what they
had was influence and their influence
was based on who they were that is it
was based on them these you know they
were supposed to be wise men men that
were recognized by all as as having uh
as having Authority in their person in
their example in their lineage you know
the fact that they were part of certain
families and so it was really it has
something to do with who they were which
was giving them Authority
so you can see how this directness of a
person's like I did I have done great
deeds in the past and because of these
great Deeds I'm chosen to be on the
senate or you know I come from this
lineage that's been important in the
city of Rome and so because of that I am
now in this influential position but the
Senators didn't have power to execute
anything and that that that power to
execute was what we call protestas which
was magistrates and different uh people
would receive
a the power to do things so some of the
power would be to enact certain laws the
some of the power could be to do certain
projects and then sometimes it would be
to go to war and so the ultimate power
would be something like Imperium which
would be the the the power that is
granted to you to now go out and fight
on behalf of Rome and to accumulate uh
other lands and and riches from other
people in the name of Rome and so you
can see how those two are related now
the patestas would would be would come
from the Senators to a certain extent
that is the Senators would give advice
would would suggest would tell people
what they should do but that telling had
no legal
had no legal weight it only had legal
weight if it was enacted in in in other
parts of their of their system toward
the magistrates would then enact that
law now what happened in the emperor is
that those Powers were brought together
in one person and so that's why we see
that the the emperor is
addressing with his right hand like a
senator but he's also holding that
scroll and that scroll is seen as by by
Art historians as also a stand-in for
potesta that is it's the law that's
written down it's the edict that's
written down it's like this is what
we're gonna do it's the it's the you
know it's the paper that makes it that
that he can show to others to prove that
he's allowed to do what he's doing okay
and so one is direct
and has that that um that direct
influence of authority and the other is
indirect because it's written down and
because it's it's it comes from above
you could say uh and is implemented in
the world and so this structure of
authority and and power of attorneys and
protestas became the the backdrop for
the manner in which
um
all of Christianity both the the East
and the West understood their their
legal system okay
um and it comes in the in Christianity
that same kind of structure of these two
Direct in direct and indirect influence
of a uh comes all the way down in a
certain image which we call the
traditions and traditional clavis which
is a a western tradition especially but
you see it in
you see it in very early uh uh art and
it gets developed in the Middle Ages
where you see on the one hand Christ
giving to the one on his right Saint
Peter he gives the keys and to the one
on his left Saint Paul he gives the book
and so the keys of course the keys are
the same as as the addressing it's like
the keys are a direct influence right
with the keys I can open and close I can
bind and I can unbind things I can you
know I can make I can bring them
together or I can let them loose and so
this is a direct influence that Christ
gives to the apostles and it's
represented as being given to Saint
Peter and then of course there is the
new law this more external aspect the
new rules the book which is given to
Saint Paul and so that makes sense with
Saint Paul representing also the Apostle
to the Gentiles the Apostle to the
outside herb himself being an outsider
be being uh you know the uh the
illegitimate Apostle you could say and
with Saint Peter holding the keys um
and being the stand-in the the stone on
which Christ built his church and so you
can understand and it's super
interesting to see how that relationship
can sometimes be fruitful like in the
case here where we represent them as the
two pillars of the church this yakin and
Boaz that hold the church together but
they can also sometimes become hostile
and and it's interesting because in the
way they can become hostile there's like
a crossing over which happens and it
would have to again with this crossing
over of the of the of the the left and
the right and you can see that with
Saint Peter and Saint Paul on the
question of circumcision which is
interesting uh which is circumcision is
the manner in which someone was marked
in order to participate in the center
uh but it's also a kind of external Mark
and so there's this interesting thing
going on in Saint Paul challenges Saint
Peter about circumcision uh
and saying that you don't need this
external Mark in order to participate in
the in the body of Christ you have to be
circumcised in your heart you know and
so he brings it inside and so there's
this interesting Dynamic that is
happening that that plays with this
crossing over of the left and the right
that I've talked about uh in the last
video uh so you can meditate on that
because it's sometimes hard to keep them
in your mind but if you if you perceive
it slowly you'll notice that there
really is this Duality but this Duality
that crosses over
um
and of course this uh relationship will
happen in many guises it will happen in
the West in terms of the relationship
between the the pope and the emperor
between the pope and the king and so
here the direct or higher or uh direct
influence will now start to be seen as
spiritual influence and the power the
protestas the executive power will then
be seen as the the secular courts the
Kings the Emperors the secular
authorities and so you can understand
how this this now in some ways has been
transformed a little bit but it but it
also follows the same pattern and of
course the two-headed Byzantine Eagle is
a wonderful example of that to help you
understand this relationship of this
duality
of the the two Eagles one representing
religious Authority the other
representing temporal power being held
together by a common crown right you
could say that this is the crown of
Christ or something like that there's a
higher crown and then there that Crown
gets separated into two crowns one which
is which is uh Spiritual Authority on
the other is temporal power and in this
particular version you hope you can see
it you can see that it's very explicit
that that's what at least this version
is dealing with because the one Talon of
the ego is holding across and the other
Talon of the eagle is holding what's
called a Globus Crusader which is a
symbol of temporal power now this
symbolism is fractal and so
you could there can be different
versions of that and so it's not always
spiritual and temporal but it will
always have this duality of direct and
indirect or uh let's say masculine and
feminine sometimes and so for example a
good example would be like a king would
hold in his hand a rod and uh and a
Globus and he's like he would he would
have a scepter in his right hand and a
Globus in his right in his left hand and
so you you have a straight and curved a
straight and crooked thing a round thing
and a straight thing and you can
understand how the right one has to do
with authority that is it's like you
point at things and you say this right
you point with your with your uh staff
at things like a magician points at his
staff at things and with his left hand
it's the thing that he's holding he's
holding the globe in his hand and so
it's a kind of it's a it's a holding of
land or a holding of power or a holding
of this protestas and so you could have
different versions of that so there are
some versions of the do to headed ego
where instead of having a cross and a
Globus the ego will have a sword and a
Globus or you know it could it could
have I don't know if it exists but there
could be one that has a a um a staff and
a Globus you know and so it
it doesn't always refer exactly to the
same particulars but the structure is
there that you can recognize being
repeated over and over
so you can understand in the manner in
which it would happen there would be
different
ways that it would be played out in the
world this relationship between between
Authority and power between the right
hand and the left hand uh sometimes it
would it could be fractal like even down
at the you can notice how fractal it is
if you look at the keys here for example
and so again Saint Peter for example
hold the keys but you can understand
that one of those keys is on the right
hand and one of those keys is on the
left hand they kind of cross over
because one is to bind and one is to
unbind one is to tighten in the center
and one is to loosen so you can
understand that it's it happened
fractally so even on the right you have
it can be repeated at different levels
where you have again the same symbolism
which is repeated so that's important to
understand because sometimes if you
don't understand that it's fractal it
can become confusing because you're like
okay well then why so if left is
something like unbinding pushing away
like Saint Christ says about the goats
and and uh right is something like
binding or bringing in so then why does
Saint Peter have the two Keys went to a
lock and went to unlock went to bind and
went to unbind and so it has to do with
that and so you could say that Saint
Peter as a stand-in for the center has a
left and a right hand himself and can
manifest that at a lower level
um so that's just a little hint to
understand that as well and so this can
play out in different ways so for
example in the the in the Middle Ages of
course Charlemagne for example was was
crowned by the uh by the pope and and in
the but there's always like a test if
the if the two sides don't get along
together the two sides can fight for the
crown right The Lion and the Unicorn
fighting for the crown you see that in
the in that type of imagery where you
have on the one hand the unicorn with
its with its one horn with its with its
staff with its representation of a
stand-in for the central thing and then
the line that is the powerful you know
Beast that will devour and that will
that that is violent and so you can
understand that the symbolism is
everywhere if you if at some point you
can see it so for example in the
Byzantine representation
there'll be all kinds of play related to
this so for example the uh the you know
of course the patriarch would Crown the
emperor but then the emperor in church
would come up to the the
um to the holy place and would usually
bring the offering to the holy place
it's like I am the the one in the world
who is dealing with all this stuff and
so I bring it to the holy place and then
it's brought into the the holy place in
order to be consecrated and so there are
different ways in which this would play
out but it's important to kind of
understand these two aspects to
understand them of course
in the world but also to understand that
they're related to to uh
to the way we look at the Christian art
and so I want to look again at this
Transfiguration because the
Transfiguration
and what's important about this the
reason why I want to look at it is
because in the in the last video I
talked about the relationship between
Elijah and James and then between Moses
and Saint Peter and how there's this
crossover but symbolism works on many
levels at the same time and so there's
also a manner in which in the Bible this
right and left hand is also related to
the prophetic and the Priestly and so
you see that of course in in the in our
tradition as well where you have the
Saints and then you have the the priest
and the the official let's say um
the official structure of the church one
is direct and flexible right the
prophetic is direct and is if it's not
not careful it can it can sometimes uh
be a little too flexible you could say
and then the other is indirect because
it's a hierarchical structure you know
that is functional but then it is also
fixed it has a more fixed aspect so you
can see that in the image of of of the
Transfiguration where Elijah now in this
case represents the the prophetic and
this direct relationship to God and then
Moses is the one who receives the law
and so also has this external part to
him so it's fractal so Christ is
blessing with his right hand and he's
holding a scroll in his left hand but
then on his right he has Elijah who is
this direct uh this image of the prophet
and the direct relationship and then
Moses who is the book and the indirect
and so I know this can sound to some
people like it's a contradiction between
what I said in the last video but
hopefully you'll start to be able to see
how symbolism is not a system and and it
has coherence and that coherence uh can
manifest itself at different levels but
it's not the type of coherence which can
be reduced to assist to a system it's
more it's coherent like a poem or
coherent like a song
um and so it can function at different
levels at the same time so hopefully
this was useful for you to understand a
little bit more about how important this
relationship of the right and left is
and maybe you can meditate a little bit
about how if in the ancient world the
right and the left were seen as
Authority and and potential and power uh
how it is that right and left today are
used in ways that are symbolically
accurate to represent the basic divide
in our political thinking and I think
that if you start to think of the
crossover of how some of these
categories cross over it might help you
understand the the uh
the manner in which the right and the
left because some people are surprised
like some people are saying why is it
that the left wants more government and
it's like think about it think about it
in the terms that I'm telling you about
this crossover uh between that which is
indirect and moving away in that which
is also fixed uh whereas the other side
is direct and and related on authority
of the of the person uh but is also more
flexible and so that's something that
you can think about maybe go nuts in the
comments and we'll see what happens so
thanks everybody for your attention and
I will talk to you very soon